testing 1 million 2 million 3 million s
work ok I'd like to talk to you about
your financial future and I hope those
figures become applicable to all of you
as we go along and I'd like to start by
posing a problem for you and instead I'm
just going to talk for a couple minutes
and we'll do Q&A because what we want to
do is talk about what's on your mind but
I'd like you to think about this for
just a second if as we walked out of
here today I said I would like to buy
10% of your financial future I was going
to write you a check today and from this
day forth you were going to give me 10%
of everything you heard how much would
you want to charge me for that I'm gonna
buy 1/10 of you and I may take the
little bit incidentally so be careful
what you write now well I think if you
thought about that a little while as you
you can contemplate that for a few
minutes you know you're gonna get a
check for me today and you can do
anything you want with the money but
from this day forth you have to give me
10% of what you earn I think it would be
very foolish of you any of you if you
asked for less than say $50,000 now it's
gonna be a few years before you're out
earning money and so I've got a few
years of dead money there but then I
would start getting this royalty on you
as you went along so I really think that
if you thought about it you know most of
you would want a fair amount more than
that I think you'd be right
fortunately I didn't make this deal with
anybody when I started out so and
nobody's got a 10% royalty on me but I
think that 50,000 would sort of be the
absolute minimum and if you think about
that that means the right today
you are worth five hundred thousand be
because of 10 percent of you is worth
fifty thousand in cash today your
potential is worth a minimum on a
hundred percent basis of five hundred
thousand dollars that is the big
financial
that you've got it's way more important
what you do with that $500,000 asset
that you own today then whether you
decide to buy stocks or bonds or whether
you put your money in a mutual fund or
pick your own stocks or anything of that
sort the biggest financial asset that
you have going for you by miles is the
value of your own earning power over the
years so that's really what you should
focus on if you're focusing on your
financial future
that means you should fame focus on you
because whether your ten percent is
worth fifty thousand or a hundred
thousand or three hundred thousand which
would be five hundred thousand or a
million or three million for all of you
whether it turns out to be one or the
other is really dependent in a very
large part on what you do in the next
few years all of you in this room have
the brains to do extremely well in life
you've all got the energy to do
extremely well in life and then the
question is how do you apply it if
you've got a 200 horsepower motor you
get 200 horsepower out of it you get
your full potential or do you get a
hundred horsepower or fifty horsepower
now there's two things that can hold you
back in getting the full horsepower out
of your your engine whatever it may be
all of you have big enough engines and
one of those is a lack of education but
that probably isn't going to happen to
very many people in this room if you did
have a lack of education if you didn't
have a chance to get a decent education
in life it wouldn't make any difference
what that potential was because you'd
never unlock it but the second most
important thing and equally as important
is in terms of the habits that you
develop in terms of what you do with
yourself when we hire people we look for
three qualities we look for integrity we
look for intelligence and we look for
energy but if they don't have the first
one integrity the other two will kill
you because if you're hiring somebody
without integrity you really wanted to
be dumb and lazy don't you I mean you
know last thing in the world you want
for them is to be smart and energetic so
smart and energetic only goes with
integrity the nice thing about you know
you make your own decision on that you
can't change your IQ or how far you can
throw a football or how high you can
jump or the color of your hair very
easily but you can elect to have
integrity that matches anybody else's
and if you match that with intelligence
which you have and energy which you have
you will get an extraordinary result and
you'd be very foolish to sell me ten
percent of yourself for fifty thousand
on the other hand if you don't match it
with that your potential will in a
significant part go unused and I'll give
you a little simple test to apply in
terms of thinking about the kind of
habits you want to develop because you
can have any habits you want to pay you
can be you can be lazy you can be prompt
you can be you can be late you can be
honest you can cut corners I mean you
have all these choices and those are
choices for you to make nobody else is
gonna make them for you and I would
suggest that you play this little game
with me to think about the person you
would most like to be in life so maybe
it's one of your contemporaries maybe
it's somebody a little older but pick
out the person you admire the most the
person that you change places with it if
you could and then write down why you
admire them just put it on a piece of
paper and then figure out the person
that you would least like to change
places with you who really turns you off
when you find repulsive and lets the
reasons why that person turns you off so
much and put those down on the other
side of the paper and then look at that
list and you'll find that everything on
the left-hand side what you admire in
other people the qualities they bring to
life cheerfulness you know generosity
all kinds of things you'll find those
are things you can do yourself it's very
simple you got apply yourself but the
habits you form in doing that early on
will carry you through life and on the
other hand you'll find that the things
that make people repulsive selfishness
obnoxiousness all these things
ecoute ism are things that no one has to
have if you find those in yourself you
can get rid of them as long as
get rid of them early so all I suggest
is that you write it write down a list
of what which admire what you find
contemptible and decide that you know
the ones on the on the admired side are
ones you're going to acquire for
yourself now if you do that when you're
young it will carry you through the rest
of your life this doesn't work if you do
it when you're 50 or 60 by then the
habits are too well formed but if you do
it early behavior becomes becomes a
habit so if you do that two or three
years - now if you go through the same
exercise you'll find out the person you
admire the most is yourself that can be
a little dangerous under some
circumstances but it but it's not it's
not a bad thing I mean you want to be
somebody you like and you don't want to
be somebody that you're that you dislike
and and form those habits early you
basically can't miss now I'll give you
one other small piece of advice that's
just a corollary on this and then we'll
get to your questions and and that is as
a general matter is a one piece of
specific finance financial advice I
would say you know avoid credit cards
just forget about it
we're in various businesses that issue
credit cards the American public loves
credit cards but if you start revolving
debt on credit cards you're gonna be
paying eighteen or twenty percent and
you can't make progress in your
financial life going around borrowing
money at eighteen or twenty percent you
can make a lot of money by lending out
at eight or 18 or 20 percent over time
if you can find anybody that's good that
will borrow from you but you don't want
to be on the side of the equation that's
always behind in life you know I was
lucky I'd saved about ten thousand
dollars by the time I got out of school
that ten thousand dollars was really
worth millions I might have learned
later on because after you get a family
and everything leave the expenses roll
in but but those were my tools to work
with but it was only because I was ahead
of the game if you're behind the game by
ten thousand dollars at some point and
paying eighteen or twenty percent
interest on it you will never you know
you'll never get out of it so the trick
I've got a partner that says all I want
to know is where I'm going to die so
never go there and and that's true in
financial matters as well you want to
figure out where you don't want to be
ahead of time and avoid that and I get
about a dozen letters a day from people
who are having terrible problems and
there are two reasons why they have
terrible problems one is a number of
them have had health problems of some
sort I mean they have really been hit by
some or somebody and their family's been
hit by some kind of catastrophic illness
and that is it you know it's a terrible
thing to happen to any family and they
get in they run up bills they can't pay
and and really only society can solve
that one in terms of protecting people
against that that's just plain bad luck
but the other one is from people who run
a credit card debt and they're facing
bankruptcy or they've been put through
bankruptcy once before and they all a
whole bunch of money and they can't they
can't even pay the interest let alone
pay any principal and the half of my
letters come from people like that and
that that that problem is avoidable
catastrophic illness is not but but
credit card debt is something you bring
on yourself and it's a way better it's
way easier to stay out of trouble than
to get out of trouble financially and I
will guarantee if you run a big credit
card that's you will be in trouble
probably the rest of your life in terms
of your financial situation on the other
hand if you get ahead of the game even
it's on a very modest scale so that
money is coming in from investing and
your your you people owe you money or
equities over you ownership you'll be
way ahead of the game compared to paying
it being always been paying your
creditors every month so my advice to
you is if you can't pay for it don't buy
it and get yourself in a position where
you can pay for anything and then we'll
be glad to see it bore Shyam's or the
risk of furniture marking that down now
let's let's have some questions do we
have a mic out there that people can
either go to or that travels around and
i can't necessarily see too well from
we're gonna have one mic on each side so
just raise your hand and wait for us to
come to you okay we have somebody up
front of like a mic
anything that's on your mind asked about
don't don't company bashful yeah how
would you advise people who aren't
necessarily going into a career field in
which you would make a large base salary
such as like medicine or something like
that maybe performing arts or music how
would you advise us to keep up
financially with the rest of the world
well it is true that a market system
does not pay as well as some in some
activities as as might seem appropriate
for the importance of those activities
the society just take teaching for
example I mean teaching does not pay
well and what could be more important I
mean I you know you've got to be as as
interested in who you're to the teachers
of your children are as who your account
does or you know whatever or who's
winning the heavyweight title of the
world or that sort of thing but but it
doesn't it doesn't pay well and and it's
a fundamental choice whether you're
going to go into something for many
people it'd be a fundamental choice
whether you're going to go into
something you love or something to to
try and make a lot of money I think that
generally it pays to go with what you
love and I think that it's very hard to
find people when they get to be my age
who say they're done that they've loved
what they've done all their life and
feel was very worthwhile but they're
terribly sad they made that choice
because they didn't make a lot of money
I don't think anybody's ever ever said
that to me that they wish they'd gone
into something else where they were
uncomfortable doing it or didn't enjoy
it didn't feel very productive but made
a lot of money so I don't I don't think
you'll find that so I would I would I
would go to work I would go to work in
whatever turns you on it may turn out
that it'll be more profitable than then
you can think but almost everybody here
will make enough money unless they get
some terrible habits along the way to do
reasonably well and doing reasonably
well in this country really is
is is pretty darn good I mean manat
necessary to have huge amounts of money
in order enjoy yourself I enjoyed myself
when I was at my $10,000 and I live in
the same house that I lived in when I
was making it when I had about that I
bought it 41 years ago I like the house
then I like the house now I mean if you
think about it if you have a reasonable
job you'll be eating at McDonald's and
I'll be eating McDonald's so we're we're
to push on food I mean you know I open
in fact I hope it's Dairy Queen actually
and done and if you come to Dairy Queen
you'll see me and you can order anything
on the menu I can order and we both can
afford it you know you'll you'll wear
the same clothes I wear I'll pay more
for my suits but as soon as I put them
on they look cheap on me so we'll look
about the same and we'll both live in
the same kind of houses I live in that
house from 41 years ago and it's it's
it's warm and winter and it's cool and
summer and it's comfortable and you live
in a house that's that similar and and
what difference does it make if you have
50 more rooms or you know guest houses
are all that it you know it'll probably
just bring your problems I mean you have
to worry about the about the
greenskeeper or something when you get
through a Saw III I have been in the
houses of people where the houses are
worth oh probably two hundred times what
my house is worth and I would not be any
happier in those houses at all in fact
I'd be less happy I just have one more
thing to to worry about you know dozens
of people around the place and people
quitting and people stealing from you
all kinds of things to hell with it yeah
we drive we'll drive the same kind of
car back you probably drive a better car
I Drive a cars about eight years old I
don't know what it's worth now but it
gets me around fine I mean I'm perfectly
happy we'll watch well what's the same
television you know well we'll work on
the same computer pretty much the only
difference will be how we travel long
distances
you know I will fly in a plane that's
more comfortable limited than flying
Southwest Airlines or something at which
I've got nothing against but that's the
one real big difference and other than
that I do what I like every day I hope
you
you like everyday to do and I work with
nice people I hope you work with nice
people and there's 24 hours in the day
and those are where the hours go so
great wealth is the tiniest bit
different in a real sense than having
just a decent a decent income and and to
trade a decent income and something you
love doing and something where you feel
worthwhile doing it for huge wealth
where you trade off a lot of your
principles would be a terrible mistake
would you not acknowledge your success
more on yourself or from hope and
teachings of others well I had I had I
was very lucky in life if you tell me
who your heroes are I will make a pretty
good prediction about how what you're
going to do and I I had the right heroes
I was very lucky in life and my heroes
never let me down and started with my
dad and then I had others in business
and so I have had great teachers some
formal teachers some that were just the
informal teachers teachers by instinct
or example and if I hadn't had those you
know my life I'm sure would have been
very different if I'd been born anyplace
else when I was I was born in 1930 and
at the time one out of 50 worst in the
world were in the United States so I
came in against fifty to one odds
against being born the United States I
would have I would have been a disaster
you know if I'd been born in Afghanistan
or or Peru or someplace I mean I was
explored wasn't I won the lottery that I
was born you know by being born in this
country so of you I mean you look you
the odds were probably forty to one
against you being born in this country
and there were five times more likely
they've been born in in China six times
have four or five times more likely have
been born in in in India or some other
place where it would not have been as
easy to exploit the full potential your
talent so we've all won the lottery in
that respect in and that's just plain
luck I mean it and I was lucky to be
born at this time I mean capital
allocation is something that pays off
extremely well in this society now but
it doesn't pay off in other societies
and it didn't pay off you know many
years ago my my friend Bill Gates says
that if I was born a few thousand years
ago I'd have been some animals lunch you
know I I can't run very fast and I can't
climb trees and you know I just happen
those are talents that nobody asked me
to climb trees now but there was a time
when it might have been important and
incidentally Bill would have been
breakfast I mean he can't run so fast
either but in any event you know we are
lucky I mean just imagine being poor in
a couple hundred years ago with exactly
the same talents and how far they would
have taken you then you know the average
person that they lives so much better
than the richest person with a hundred
or hundred and fifty years ago so lucky
in that respect lucky to be born of
terrific parents I was lucky to be
raised in Omaha and in a great public
school system I got a start here in the
first eight grades that gave me a
foundation that later when I went off
the track a few times carried me through
because I had a terrific grade school
education in right here and on the hill
and one of the reasons I had it
incidentally it's kind of unfortunate
but I had that great education in part
because women were being enormous ly
discriminated against and so a woman at
that time could be a teacher she could
be a secretary she could be a nurse you
know and that was about it so you had a
half the talent pool in the United
States limited to just a few jobs so you
had a abundance of talent in those
activities like nursing or teaching
because that talent with males was
spread across every act every form of
work activity there was but with women
it was concentrated in a few areas and
that that benefit be it's kind of sad
because it didn't benefit those teachers
but but I was very lucky and I've really
been that way all my life and what I do
is what I do is important this you know
what a good teacher does or good nurse
does or something of a sort you know I
think that's quite questionable it pays
off enormous ly well in a market economy
like the United States and but that's an
accident didn't any do any innate
ability of mine
my name is marina said and I attend
Omaha Central High School for you mr.
Buffett technology has been a great
factor in stimulating the world economy
what are your predictions for the future
of the technology industry and was what
is its future role in world economy and
the United States economy
yeah well it's there's no question it's
turning the world upside down it's it's
Dunn's done it somewhat already but it
will you know it's just beginning
but it's moving very fast I met gates on
July 15th 1991 who was out there for 4th
of July celebration with a friend and
who subsequently died made green fields
of the Washington Post and she took us
down to visit the gates family and he
tried to educate me about high tech and
he'd had better luck with chimpanzees I
mean I was I was really a disaster but
that but he's a good teacher but he one
thing he told me was that at the time he
said you know you've got this model in
your head of the world and your model
has time and distance as very limiting
factors and he said they aren't limiting
factors anymore he said you know the
cost of talking to somebody around the
world or getting your message in front
of somebody or publishing is it it's
going to be zero and they're so close to
zero it doesn't make any difference and
you know that was revolutionary but it's
happening already in a in a very very
big way
and it's just what eight years later and
and it's it's exploding so high-tech
information technology whatever you want
to call it is changing the world and
it's going to change it in a very very
big way it'll change and that's one of
the things I think about it businesses
we buy we announced the purchase
yesterday of a furniture retailer in
Boston in the Boston area and you know I
think to myself what effect does this
new world have in terms of the internet
on furniture retail I mean you have to
think about questions like that the
changes will be huge I will I played
bridge yesterday with
all over the country but I played it
with people all over the world I just
sit down at my computer and I've got
some popcorn there and I'm in khakis and
a sweater and I I can have a bridge game
in 30 seconds with people all over the
world and no cost to it basically you
know that's a lot different than trying
to arrange a game with four people in
Omaha you know on a day when one guy
wants to play golf another wants to
watch baseball I mean it's it it just it
changes things in a huge way we are very
fortunate I mean it's in the degree to
which the United States leads the world
in this area I mean we have a lead it's
hard to think of who's in second place
and 15 or so years ago this country had
an inferiority complex it'd be hard for
you to remember because you weren't old
enough to be around them but in the in
the early 80s we were wondering whether
the Germans and the Japanese were going
to own everything and that they were
going to make all the steel and they
were going to make all their cars and
everything else and the television sets
and we were going to flip hamburgers
that was the standard line and just
imagine in a short period like 15 years
how that's changed around in an
important way that's changed because of
this information revolution where we
like I said I don't know who I don't
know who you would name as being in
second place in the world but here's the
most important industry in the world and
the United States has this incredible
position and we're moving all the time
with that position so I think that
argues for a very I think it argues for
a terrific future for the world over
time and I think it argues even more for
a terrific future for this company a
country one of the best ways for youth
to get started now in securing their
financial future for for what to secure
their financial future are you youth
well it's not it's not very complicated
it goes back to getting full use out of
your own talents first I mean the
difference between whether you're going
to be earning X or 2x or 3x a year 20
years from now is going to be a function
of how well not how much talent you have
but how well you use the talents you
already have and so that is the your
best financial future is your own
ability and and and your capacity to to
use those abilities to their potential
and they can't take that can't be taken
away from you they can't even tax it I
mean you know most things if you and I
you know a piece of real estate if they
double the taxes they double the taxes
and that changes your ownership in the
property because now in fact the taxing
authorities own more of it because
they've got a greater command on the
revenue stream the same thing about
almost any assets you have but they they
don't tax what's in your head and they
don't tax your ability to start
performing when you when you get to work
in the morning and finish in the evening
to to your potential one of the things
that amazes me is how people who really
do perform well just sort of jump out at
you once you're running a business when
I got out of school I thought you know
everybody would behave that way but they
don't most people sort of go go through
life in a sleepwalk and and it if you
don't you will stand out so the big the
biggest thing for your financial future
is yourself now beyond that it is always
being ahead of the game rather than
getting behind the game it's saving a
little no matter how you doing I mean I
delivered papers I worked at pennies I
sold golf balls out of pinball machine
around I did a lot of things that
enabled me to cumulate about ten
thousand dollars by the time I got out
of school
ten thousand doesn't go as far now as it
did then but it having anything so that
you're ahead of the game and not getting
behind the game is enormous ly important
I mean just you know if you're gonna run
a hundred 100-yard dash against a bunch
of people in life if you can figure it
out so that when the gun goes off you're
ten or fifteen yards ahead instead of
ten or fifteen yards behind it's going
to make an enormous difference in how
that race comes out so having having
some net resources doesn't make much
difference whether they're in stocks or
bonds in my view
and not having debt when that gun goes
off when you get out of school is a huge
plus over being behind the game and you
know it makes them from delivering a
paper out in the morning it may be come
from a part-time work someplace but but
put aside a few dollars for yourself so
that when the time comes in the enter
the end of the work force you're ahead
of the game and not behind and then once
you get there don't get behind by buying
a whole lot of things that you figure
you're going to pay for some day while
you're paying twenty percent interest in
between students if you could please say
your name and school when you ask a
question hard for me to see we even
where the microphone is but I
my name is Patrick Dougherty and I'm
from billions of us the high school I
was wondering with the increasing costs
of education today what can students do
to deal with their debts once they're
out of college well that's a tough one I
mean I guess I'd pay it off as fast as I
could and I would incur as little debt
as as possible in in before that time
came and I would say this in my
experience in business there is very
little difference if any between a very
high priced business education and
what's available a lot for a lot less
money so I I mean I I went to the
University of nebraska-lincoln my last
year in college I went to Wharton for a
couple years before that I learned just
as much at University of Braska as I did
at Wharton at and there's nothing
against Wharton I mean it's just me we
had a very good school there I had some
terrific professors at Lincoln and so I
I would not assume that if I was paying
a few thousand dollars for an education
here in the state for example versus
paying huge amounts elsewhere that it
was going to make a lot of difference
most a lot of the education in you need
to be prodded in the right direction but
an awful lot of it is self as self
taught I mean Andrew Carnegie did a
wonderful thing in this country in terms
of libraries and I used to spend a lot
of time the libraries having have locked
in at the University of Omaha one what
was then the University of Omaha on they
had I couldn't get out for hours and one
night I got so entranced with what I was
reading but it there's there's all kinds
of information available now with the
internet it's so much you know easier
than it was then so it's out there to be
taken and it isn't necessary to pay
thirty or thirty-five thousand dollars a
year to go to some big-name school to
get the education at all
I mean if you're gonna learn accounting
if your is the probably the most
important course you'd take in business
if you're gonna learn to count you learn
accounting absolutely as well and my
view going to you and always going to
Harvard I mean I see I would I bet on
that and so I wouldn't run up huge bills
in terms of getting a business education
now you know if you're going to get a
medical education I mean there are
certain professions where there may not
be any way around spending a fair amount
of money and getting in debt to some
degree we've got to make that decision
yourself but I'd certainly try to
minimize it and and I would sort of I
would have it figured out how I would
handle that debt and say a five-year
period after I got out of school or I
would think twice about incurring it
there's a question up here if we can
bring a microphone my name is Kyle Clark
I'm here representing Omaha Youth
Advisory Council what advice would you
have for a forming nonprofit
organization performing a nonprofit
organization well I've always tried to
avoid forming nonprofit organizations
when well that would that would depend
entirely what I wanted to accomplish I
mean it you know it the one thing it was
a hospital it could be another thing you
know if it there's there's a there's so
many types of it so I you know you've
got to get people that are that are
experienced and involved in an entity
like that and but it depends so much on
the I'm the objective you're working at
yeah but I promise this young lady here
a microphone for a long time
hi my name is Kara hardware and I attend
Millard West high school and I
understand that you're very civically
involved and I was wondering how
important of a quality you think that is
for an individual in life and why yeah
well I wouldn't say that I am that I
mean I do certain Civic things I think I
think your model as a citizen for
example in all law would be Walter Scott
I mean he is far more civically involved
than I am and incidentally his
predecessor Peter Kiewit was too but
Walters carried it to new heights so I I
don't want to take on any mammal for
that myself I do some things one of the
problems I have is I love what I do so
much that that it sort of takes over I
mean I'm like a guy that likes to play a
lot of golf or something except I like I
like the business I'm in but I've got a
family that participates very actively
some my children work on almost anything
that comes along in the Civic area and
you know it's you do in the end people
do what they want to do to quite a
degree and and I think I've never talked
to anybody that that enjoyed working in
civic activities that didn't feel that
was very worthwhile after they've done I
mean they've built something and
participating in building something is
always a lot of fun and actually have a
good time we have a golf tournament for
example in September and we raised some
money for some event but everybody has a
good time so nobody's paying any price
by doing it I'm having a good time that
people will come or having a good time
and we get to show off to people but you
should be enjoying things that go along
and you will if you work in civic
activities that that that interests you
you can do the same thing in politics I
mean it you know if you if you get if
you find political ideas or or
politicians who particularly you
identify when Tyrion you can get a lot
of self satisfaction out of out of
working and you're doing something
worthwhile so I just just follow your
instincts on that
be my recommendation
[Music]
hi my name is Jeremy Graham from Millard
South High School we're probably the I
guess the oblique youth of today and
I've questioned what do you see is the
problem the biggest economic problem
facing the youth of today going into the
future yeah I don't think that you're
going to have enormous economic problems
I think you will live in a society where
the average person lives better by a
significant margin than the average one
of a generation earlier or two
generations earlier that's been the
history of this country it's a marvelous
country that way
I mean if when you think of it we have
four-and-a-half percent of the world's
population you know and and what's been
accomplished here is incredible 53
percent of the of the value of
corporations that are publicly traded in
the world exists in the United States
with four and a half percent of the
population this country always has done
well they say in stocks that you book
should buy stock in the business that's
so good that even an idiot can run it
because sooner or later one will and and
that's not terrible advice well that
seems have been sort of the history of
this country from time to time I mean
we've we've had all these problems that
have come along if you look back in the
last hundred years and list all the
problems this country's run into you
know you make a very long list and a lot
of people who focused on those problems
at the time have missed the bigger
picture and the bigger picture is that
every generation lives better than the
one before it and that's because of
that's because of savings because
savings enable people to create new
tools to do better things as they go
along and it's also due to an
environment that lets people realize
their potential to a greater degree than
most other environments in the world
it's far from perfect I mean it's it's
it's sad how far it is from perfect but
it is better than anything else around I
mean in this country you've got you
don't have some commissar or something
running a you know a big business in
this country you've got a guy like Jack
Welsh and a fella like Jack Welch makes
a difference of night and day
in terms of the productivity of that
business over a period of decades and
productivity is whatever is what causes
the standard of living to rise so
anything that a system that throws up
the Jack Welch's of the world to run
businesses is going to have an enormous
advantage over a society that does it by
heredity or the does it by government
edict and we've got we're closer to that
society that I've described than
anything than any other country and it's
it's led to two great things and it will
continue to leave the great thing so I
think I think you've got the best future
you know you don't face you don't face a
war and you've got it you've got a great
you've got a better future in terms of
achieving material rewards than any
generation in history so I wish I could
trade you places I might get taken up on
that by a few of you though
hi I'm Ryan Wilkins from Millard West
High School and I was wondering if you
or if you could speak for mr. gates were
afraid of the impact of y2k on the
economy or specifically the stock market
yeah well I'm I'm glad you gave me a
chance to bring another people because I
I'm the last guy in the world
understanding about y2k I you know I
don't know why this microphone is
working I don't know
you know why lights go on it I I flip on
the switch of my television set and pray
I mean I say it's all it's all beyond me
but I would say this the smartest people
I know in that area in large part I
think it's going to be a non-event in
this country I don't I can't speak for
the rest of the world but so I think I
think you'll wake up on January 1st and
find that the world hasn't changed from
December 31st now I would say this you
might you might get a whole bunch of
friends to write you checks for a
billion dollars on December 31st and
deposit them and you know who knows
what'll happen can't lose anything I
mean all they do is bounce and if the
system gets fouled up you know who you
might find a lot of money in your
account but I wouldn't count on it then
wait we have a we we oughta company
called executives yet we have about
fourteen or fifteen hundred customers
who own pieces of airplanes with us and
we so we've got a hundred so we got a
hundred and sixty of their planes and
some of our own flying around it'll be
very interesting to me to see what the
advance people let us know ahead of time
when they want to use it'll be very
interesting to see how many sign up for
January 1st at 12:01 but I it wouldn't
bother me to fly him in the least on
January 1st or do anything else on
January 1st ideally I hope they were
getting prepared to watch the Huskers
play and I'm Jamie solace from Twin
Valley and I was wondering how do you
decide what you invest your time and
money
yeah well I I like to find businesses
that have good economics now what what
are good economics well good economics
are a business that has some kind of a
moat around it that makes its product or
its service or its location or something
a little more desirable than to the
customer than any other sort of
comparable product you know the number
one candy bar in the last 30 or 40 years
has been Snickers people don't fool
around with different candy bars they
fool around with different length
dresses they fool around you know with
all kinds of things but they don't fool
around with candy bars because they
figure you know they're gonna go in and
lay out 50 cents or whatever it is and
put it in their mouth and they're not
gonna for 50 cents and putting in your
mouth I mean you're not gonna sell
putting lay out 45 cents and put
something else in my mouth so you find
that very stable and we like businesses
that we think we can figure out where
they're going to be in 10 or 15 years I
don't know where the information
technology businesses are going to be in
10 or 15 years I know where Snickers
bars are gonna be in 10 or 15 years
they're going to be selling just about
this you know the way they do now I know
where Wrigley's gum is gonna be in 10 or
15 years there's not going to be a lot
of innovation in chewing them the end
people the Internet's not gonna cause
people to quit chewing gum either I mean
at least I gates me think so but I don't
think so
but it's it's predictability regarding
the sustainability of a competitive
advantage
something special about a product so we
look for those kind of products and then
we look for people than running the
business that are honest and able and
[Music]
you know that's it's easier to find
people that are honest than able than it
is to find businesses that are going to
stay wonderful for a long period of time
there are a lot of businesses that
looked like they were going to stay
wonderful but really evaporated over
time but that's what we're looking for
and the nice thing about is we don't
have to find very many if we find one a
year that's terrific
because you don't you don't need a
hundred or a thousand great investment
ideas to well you need a couple and if
we the discipline is the most important
thing we don't need brain power
we need discipline that you don't need
150 IQ to do what I do thank God you
know you don't need 140 you know 135 you
may need 115 or something like that and
and but you do need discipline you have
to wait until you see the fat pitch to
swing at because investing is a know
called strike game you know if I were a
baseball player and I only like pitches
two inches above my navel you know some
guy could learn that and he could pitch
me you know three or four inches below
that and I get called out on strikes
because I never find a pitch I like you
can get called out on strikes in
baseball you have to you have to swing
at pitches that you you don't even
necessarily like particularly after the
count gets the two strikes in business
you don't have to swing at anything you
can sit there and the paper says General
Motors at 68 or says General Electric of
115 or says General Dynamics at 63 and
if you don't like those prices you don't
have to swing you can wait there day
after day after day after day and there
are no called strikes now when you swing
when you decide to buy something then
you know if you're swinging this it's a
strike but it's a marvelous game to be
in because there are no called strikes
and you can simply wait for that one
time in a month or six months or a year
or two or three years when you really
know what you're doing where you like
the price we like the people running the
business and then you swing and you only
need a few swings in your lifetime so
that's the way we try to pick businesses
we try to stay with things we understand
I mean there can be all kinds of
wonderful investment opportunities out
there that I don't understand I don't
know what cocoa beans are gonna do next
year you know maybe you know but I don't
know I I don't know what I don't know
what crude oil is gonna sell for but I
don't have to know I just have to know
what the things I have to know what I
know I have to know where the limits of
my understanding are what I call what my
circle of competence is and if I'm only
able to evaluate 5% of the businesses in
the world no problem I just stay within
that 5% and try and find something and
that's most people get in trouble
because in investments because they
will they get itchy you know they can't
discipline themselves and they hear
about other people making money nothing
upsets people so much as to hear about
their friends making money I mean it's
that that's very destructive to
discipline because they think I'm
smarter than a guy next door and he just
just bought that new car with the money
made trading stocks on the internet so I
can't I well the answer is you can't
over time you will lose money to trade
stocks actively and it's it's hard to
exercise the discipline but anytime you
buy something you should be able to take
out a one page sheet of paper and say
I'm buying General Motors it's sixty
five I'm buying General Electric one
hundred and fifty big cause and you
should write down the reasons if you
can't if you can't fill out the sheet if
it's because somebody told me about it
at a cocktail party last night that's
not good enough if it's because my
broker told me about it that's not good
enough
yeah it's you've got to have a reason
for thinking that it makes an
intelligent investment you do the same
thing if you're buying a farm or an
apartment house if you're buying a farm
you'd say I'm buying this farm and
thousand dollars an acre because I think
I can earn sixty dollars an acre on it
if corn sells and such and such and
soybean sells and such and such and
yield is such and such and you'd figure
it out that's the same reason you buy
businesses and when you buy stocks
you're buying a little piece of a
business and that's probably the most
important thing to remember and in
investing is that when you are buying a
stock you're buying a little piece of
the business and if you are buying it at
an attractive price for the business for
the whole business you're going to make
money and if you aren't you know over
time you won't make money
hi my name is Brooke McAvoy with ol
Carmel Michael um Reverend Jackson Jesse
Jackson talked to us earlier he seemed
to believe that the moral standards of
today's society will eventually affect
us in business how do you feel this will
affect us as youth growing up in the
United States
he said the moral standards will affect
us how business by how we feel how we
interact with other people well I think
very difficult to quantify moral
standards over time I mean it that you
know you could you can pick out huge
weaknesses at any given time in terms of
how people or the country is behaving
and and and huge strength so I think
it's enormous ly difficult to quantify I
think by and large we have made progress
in what I would call institutionalized
moral standards in this country I mean
the the the you know in terms of slavery
in terms of the in terms of I mean the
women women couldn't vote you know a
century ago at they were half the
country were second-class citizens in
that respect in a barium and they had
much lesser rights in in terms of
inheritance and all kinds of things the
income tax didn't exist a hundred years
ago so the idea of taxing people
according to to how much that they
benefited from society and their income
didn't exist so I think in terms of
institutionalized moral standards the
country has made really quite
significant progress in the in the last
hundred years I think you know there's
an enormous distance to go I think we're
going in the right direction maybe by
fits and starts but I think we're going
in the right direction and I think that
you know the it will be a it will be a
significant toss to everybody in this
room as they live in a more moral
society forty years from now than the
less moral but I think the odds are that
they will I think the country moves in
that direction very difficult to do it
all kinds of interests that work against
it but in the end I think the American
people want it
and you saw it in civil rights I mean it
took television to dramatize what was
going on and people that weren't near it
preferred not to think about it but it
got through to the conscience of the
American people and a lot of progress
has been made there and there's a lot
left to be made but there it's better
than it was and the pace may seem very
slow to those people involved and I can
understand that
the pace you know for women's suffrage I
mean that went for decades and decades
and decades
welcome could be on a jury I was reading
the trial of Clarence Darrow which took
place in California in about nineteen I
don't know ten or eleven you know there
were no women on the jury the woman
wasn't allowed to be on a jury they
weren't citizens in that sense so it's
immoral behavior of the country has in
my view improved but it you know and
it'll continue to improve and I hope you
all in this room do your part to help it
improve
I am Nick jours from Central High and I
was wondering how since the stock
market's so high right now it could be
smart for us to get to get involved now
or to wait till until it goes down a
little or what yeah I can't tell you
whether or not to buy stocks now
generally I think it's important that
you save money you know and whether
whether you put in the stock market I
don't think it's terribly important I
think if you're interested in the stocks
you should you should buy it you know
and you've got a little capital you
should buy a few I mean I don't like
there's any way of learning about them
better than experiencing you're doing it
on paper isn't the same I can guarantee
you if you lose money on paper or lose
real money it's a different experience
and I am so I I think they're I think
you'll learn more about yourself if you
do it that way I bought my first stock
when I was 11 I was actually I was a
rose Hill at the time and I bought three
shares of city service preferred at 38
and it went down to 27 which is
something I still remember even though I
was 11 at the time and then I went up to
40 and I sold it I made five bucks on my
three shares after commissions and then
it went to two hundred and something so
you know I I probably remember that a
little better than if I'd been doing it
on paper and I fool around doing a lot
of things between about age 11 and 19 in
the stock market I did charts I did all
kinds of technical analysis I read every
book I could get on the subject and I
didn't do that well I didn't do terrible
but but I I was really just floundering
around but by that meant by the age of
19 when I read Ben Graham's book I was
at the University of Raskin Lincoln I
went and bought this book called the
intelligent investor just come out and
it had an enormous impact on me now if I
hadn't done in the previous eight years
if I hadn't been all over the lot I'm
not so sure that that book would have
had the same impact on me I mean I was
by that time I was prepared to read Ben
Graham's book which changed my life
financially and I
an incredible way I mean I wouldn't be
up here today if I had read that book
but yeah part of life is getting
prepared so that when something does
happen that's significant you can grasp
the significance of it and know what to
do with it and I would say that first
eight years of fooling around even
though it produced nothing financially
to speak of produced a lot in terms of
getting my mind prepared for what I
really did read something that made
sense so I was ready to accept it and I
actually went back and went to Columbia
to study under the under Graham and
because of of reading that book and all
kinds of things flowed out of it so I
would encourage you if you're interested
in the field to to do a few things I'd
still try and make up as intelligent as
possible I would try to stick with
things businesses I thought I understood
I'd still get out that sheet of paper
and I'd write I'm doing this because and
just test my reasoning and then I go
back and read it a year later and and
see whether what you thought would be
true turned out to be true so I would
always check myself I believe in grading
myself on everything you know doctors
have post-mortems and they do it because
they learn from post-mortems and
business people don't like to do
post-mortems what I can be on the board
of a company and they can on ours
building plants or buying companies and
they never wanted two years later to run
a check on how that decision turned out
because it it can be unpleasant but you
learn from post-mortems and you don't
want to learn it's way better to learn
from other people's mistakes in your own
but you got to learn from a few of your
own - and the time to do it is when
you're young we can do maybe one more
and then we wrap this up at wonder where
maybe maybe two more my name is Pete
Walsh I'm from Creighton Prep and my
question is to what extent do you feel
that the government with the current
policies of welfare and Social Security
is it financially competent and fiscally
prepared for the future well I think
that
the country as a whole is quite quite
well prepared for the future that
doesn't mean I'd adopt would adopt every
policy they have but but I think a we
have an enormous Lee rich society
enormous Lee rich society and it'll get
richer
everyone isn't going to participate in
that some will participate because if
physical disabilities others because of
mental disabilities other because of
shortcomings in the education they
received when they were growing up all
kinds of reasons we have a prosperous
enough society to be able to take care
of of those people and we should take
care of them and how we do it so that
they feel most useful in life and how we
do it so that we continue to encourage
people to be more productive themselves
in all that I mean those are not easy
questions but but that shouldn't take
our eye off the ball of feeling we
should do something about it
I often I pose this problem sometimes to
people I say let's assume that it's 24
hours before you're born and all of you
can take this test 24 hours before
you're born and a genie comes to you and
the genie says what was your name again
out there whatever is they'll call you
Joe and the genie says Joe says you look
pretty promising to me I think you've
got kind of a sense of fair play and at
a good mind and so I'm gonna let you
have an extraordinary opportunity I'm
going to let you design the world into
which you're going to be born in 24
hours it's yours you pick out the
political rules you pick out the
economic rules you pick out the social
rules you design the world and when
you're born in 24 hours you're gonna be
born into that world and that's the
world that's gonna exist for your
lifetime for your children's lifetime
for your grandchildren's lifetime and
you having heard of some of these Genie
jokes in the past would say what's the
catch a genie says well it's a very
slight catchment I said when you're born
in 24 hours you're going to emerge in
this world you designed but what you
don't know is whether you're going to be
born black or white male or female rich
or poor brighter [ __ ] able-bodied or
infirm in the United States or
Afghanistan all you know is that you're
going to reach into this barrel which
now has six billion balls as we know
representing one person every person in
the world and you're gonna participate
in what I call the ovarian lottery
you're gonna take one ball out of that
barrel and you're never gonna get
another ball that's you you're gonna get
one ball and now you're gonna emerge now
what kind of rules you want to have for
that Society not knowing which ball
you're gonna get now that I put to you
is the way I think people should think
about Social Policy and if you're born
if you're lucky enough to be born in
this country you've won the lottery
already but we should have a system in
my view that encourages the Jack Welch's
and the Bill Gates's and all of that to
work far beyond the time when it has any
economic significance to them we want
people commanding those resources who
are extremely able to commanding them
that's how that's how the standard of
living moves forward so we should want
you know we should want Tom Osborne
coaching a Nebraska we should want we
should want Bill Gates designing
software and we don't want to mix up
those two we don't want to we don't want
to get bill coaching in Nebraska so you
want you want people you want a system
that directs gets people to their
potential and and puts them in the
position where they can do the most good
for society but you also want a system
for the people get the wrong ball I mean
somebody's going to get the ball you
know that says atiq somebody's gonna get
the ball that says this disease or that
disease earlier in life that cripples
them and we've got a rich enough society
that we can we can take care of those
people and I think that to get back to
your question I think that this society
will move more and more in that
direction it has the capability of
moving more and more in that direction
as our resources and our output
increases and I think that it has the
will to do that in a general way
although like I say there have always
been lots of fits and starts so there is
no shortage in the United States of
resources there's no shortage of out
what you have to have a system that
encourages people to behave to the limit
of their abilities and puts them in the
right place but then you have to make
sure that everybody gets taken care of
too now we can do one more and then we
will break things
I'll let the fellow with the microphone
woman here make the decision
hi my name is Ben gold I got a brother
tell it and I wanted to know how you
think the media affects the world
economically today well it's a small
question well what it obviously does
simply because it's it's moved so far
technologically as its brought it
together in a big way I mean I was over
in China a few years ago and I was right
after the time of the women's conference
in in in Beijing and I was reading the
Chinese coverage of that conference and
of course it it had nothing to do with
what was taking place but the internet
was coming in and and you know you can
you can access the Washington Post to
the New York Times really I get the
Washington Post at 9:30 here at night in
effect I never could get at the next day
on through through physical delivery but
I buy electronic delivery I can read it
you know there probably earlier than
most of people in Washington are reading
it so the ability to communicate and the
degree to which the world can have
awareness of what's going on every place
in the world is just you know it's been
a quantum leap and you know that will
have there are a lot of things that come
out of that and net they're a plus over
time but the they I mean they the the
ability of information to be available
to everyone worldwide almost instant
instantaneously it's it's it's a huge
advances in things like medicine for
example just to pick one so it's a net
plus it has a it has a big effect and
the definition of media has now been
expanded enormous ly I mean there were
three television networks in in the
nineteen and you know in the early 1960s
and that was it there were three
highways information traveled
electronically and if the three pieces
of information where I Love Lucy and I
want something else in something else
those are the three choices of
information or entertainment that you
had for tens and tens of millions of
people sitting there looking at a tube
now it's unlimited and that's only what
three or so decades so it's just
exploded and it'll continue to explode
and net I think it's a plus and I think
it's one o'clock I want to thank you all
I I wish you well you're going to do
terrific no thanks
[Applause]
Hey